frédéric on peut dire là c'était
vraiment une page d'histoire qui se
tourne un chat noir et d'histoire qui a
commencé il ya très longtemps en fait
grâce à cet homme qui s'appelle le
colonel samuel mac os à flaine il est à
oshawa et il s'occupe à l'époque de son
entreprise familiale qui construit des
calèches des traîneaux etc
mais lui veut passer à la vitesse
supérieure et donc il veut construire
des voitures mais il n'a pas de moteur
alors il prend contact avec cet homme
qui s'appelle william burns qui est en
fait un financier américain qui lui a
fondé general motors
donc il travaille ensemble il sort ses
premiers véhicules et pas plus tard
qu'en 1918 et bien il devient le
président de la compagnie gm canada qui
est alors fondé en 1953 on va alors
ouvrir c'est énorme usine à oshawa
évidemment ça fait beaucoup de
production de voitures et là on commence
à pouvoir faire la production de masse
de tous ces voitures qui vont faire
rêver tous les conducteurs canadiens
évidemment et puis dans les années 80 là
c'est vraiment c'est l'âge d'or on va
dire pour jim canada avec c'est énorme
usine ont investi plus de 8 milliards de
dollars de dents c'est le fameux
deuxième auto plex et on va même
évidemment engagé beaucoup de monde à
l'époque on est rendu à 23 personnes qui
travaillent pour cette entreprise là et
on va produire bon an mal an à peu près
sept cent trente mille véhicules par an
donc une croissance assez phénoménal
mais toute bonne chose a une fin
on mutile et oui malheureusement les
premiers problèmes arrivent dans les
années 2000 notamment en 2005 où l'on
commence à réduire le personnel 3750
personnes qui se retrouvent sur le pavé
on retire également la construction de
certains modèles donc évidemment ce sont
les coups durs et puis évidemment
patatras on est en 2008 c'est la
récession si le coup dur pour jamie
l'industrie automobile qui se voit
offrir un plan de sauvetage à coup de
dizaines de milliards de dollars de la
part des gouvernements américain et
canadien ça va un peu mieux mais pas
tant que ça regardait en 2009 en fait il
faut encore procéder à des
restructurations 2012 là on ferme une
partie de lusine 2013 là il ya un petit
ballon d'oxygène on propose un nouveau
modèle ou deux mais on est rendu
seulement à 275 mille voitures par an
seulement en tout cas on pourra dire que
cette usine d'oshawa reproduit bien des
modèles conduit par l'icann
mais oui évidemment l'âge d'or la belle
époque on connaît évidemment tous les
chevrolet caprice classique les bel air
les monte carlo et même la camaro mais
il y avait aussi les bio et qu'il y
avait également aussi les pontiac
aujourd'hui ce qu'il reste mais ce n'est
pas grand chose dans le fond ces quatre
modèles qui vont faisait tourner
jusqu'ici l'entreprise on l'avait
évidemment la malibu n'avait la xts de
cadillac et ses deux camions mais ce
sont des modèles qui n'excédait pas dans
leur catégorie résultat aujourd'hui ans
ferme merci beaucoup frédéric arnould a
un prix